鉱物を
他メンライザーウィザードです
サボる足立安心
# barbie つ変身
かもよイギリスにもうすぐ行きますクルーズの8人
義烏市に行くんですけど部屋の匹ハメとかもあるんでもうすぐこの部屋でて富山に帰る
んですよ
唯一いいことを備えると僕のちょっとカメラ論をハァハァさせていただけますまあ今道
金で撮ってるんですよデジタル一眼レフカ
みんなーみんなーじゃないんですけどちょっとぞ
どうやってさーこういうさ
ハンディーカメラで撮るイメージがありませんかけど一眼レフっていうのは部を
焦点はずらして部月全市専門家じゃなくて分からないんですけど
勝点をずらして
後ろのボケるんですよ例えば見てくださいよ
吠えて指を近づけると
いや言いボケてますよねけど後ろの
ぎゅっとかがはっきり見えますけどこれどこー
ちょっとエジルと
何も変わりませんよか起きたら9月になります僕にピントが合って後ろの湯が完全に
向けてますね
だっせに綺麗なんですけどはっきり言いましょう
いくつ開けだけです
これ実は20分経ったらなんか熱暴走してもう取れないってなって冷やさないといけ
なかったりポンポン的に無礼がひどい僕よく外でもってこうちょっと付 e 7を取る
んですけど
半端ないけど汚くて多分
見てる皆さんもきっと捕物用意するんで画質画質だけなんです
進めなくなって疲れたんですけどやっぱりどうだっていうのは
って
がしますよね
綺麗な動画も大事ですけど長い時間取れていろんなとこで取れて持ちながらを取れて
くれるものなんていうもの
宅麺機能と言いますかと以降政治なんていう詐害的
おっ
買ってきましたよなぁさっすぐ売っ
あげていきましょう
良さ分かってくださいね面白い来とるってこういうことなんですよ
まあたぶん10額面なさい一番の買い物ですね
cx 6件30部位です
ん
これ実写空楽手ぶれ工学
空間補正手ブレですよ壊さ銭ギレスから帰ってきたいですね
中身はこちらの紐とはちぷりと日ごと入ってますね下となってると
アップにどうだって言うとあっていいと本体です
本体はかっこいいですバッテリーじゃねーぞ
していますはっえっそうじさん大塚ないっすよ
6分
思ってくれ
まあこうでしたねそんな感じですよ
かっこいいすとりあえず
うーん
た
おっ
びっくりした場合取り方またに本日だった日本札世界つつ
トニーのハンディカメラで最後に部位がつくなって全部光学手ブレ補正がついて手振っ
たら中のメンターは動くんですよ
ブレないんです動画とってたもん
と店にとって見やすかっ
もうこれほぼメインつってもいいがいいですね
the 見てくださいね光学手ブレ補正を見せてあげましょう
ん